Speaker 1: So we have a bit of a lighthearted
story to wrap things up today, and it has to do
with one of the worst pandemic inspired changes
to our society, which is of course the dreaded
QR code at restaurants replacing physical menus.
We know that during the pandemic, businesses would
try to take advantage of the situation by not
providing us with things that we were used to
and just using COVID as an excuse. Like they would
say, Oh, sorry, we can't clean your hotel room
because of COVID and sorry you can't bring your
reusable bag to the grocery store because of
COVID. Remember that one? Well, none of these
changes were as bad as the dreaded QR code
scanner at restaurants. And while some of
the pandemic era inconveniences are no more,
the dreaded QR code at restaurants persists, and
the idea of introducing them in the first place
was pretty clear. You don't have people touching
the menus that way. You don't have to sanitize the
menus as often. And it's the same reason why
restaurants during the height of the pandemic
got rid of the ketchup bottles on the tables and
the salt and pepper shakers. And it didn't take
long for us to learn that the virus was largely
an airborne transmitted virus. It didn't really
transfer that much from surfaces. So a lot of
these changes that we made were pointless and
we could have backtracked on them right then
and there pretty early on in the pandemic.
But restaurants persisted with the QR thing
because printing menus can be expensive. You need
to replace them sometimes when they get dirty or
when you change the menu. You got to think about
the printing costs. And it's also in a low labor
environment, just better for businesses to have
the QR codes because you don't have to have staff
distribute and collect the menus, but customers
absolutely revile the QR code, myself included.
A recent Technomic survey found that about 88% of
respondents said that they preferred paper menus
to digital QR codes. About 66% of respondents
agreed or strongly agreed that they didn't like QR
codes because they involve pulling out your phone
as soon as you sit down at the table. About 57%
agreed that using QR codes felt like a chore,
and 55% agreed that QR codes were hard to read and
browse through. And it actually does seem to make
sense for restaurants to bring back the physical
menus now, not just because customers hate it.
They'll sometimes leave these awful reviews for
restaurants because of the QR codes. The QR codes
actually are leading to. People ordering less
because if you have a menu left on the table,
for example, sometimes it will have the pictures
of the food and the drinks and the desserts and
everything. So you may be tempted to order more
just by giving a glance over at it and saying, Oh,
that looks good, I want to order that. Whereas if
you have to pull out your phone, scan the QR code,
open up the website, scroll down, find what
you're looking for. That's more of an active
action versus a passive action of just glancing at
something and saying, That looks good. I want that
now. Depending on my mood, I will sometimes lie at
the restaurant and I'll say, I don't have a phone
or I have a flip phone, and so I need a physical
menu. That is something that you can try out at
home there. They'll have a few physical menus
at their ready, so they're probably not going
to be happy to give it to you. But you can always
just make up an excuse and I'm sure you'll get it.
And another pro-tip for dealing with the other
inconvenience that people absolutely hate at
restaurants is when you're about to pay for the
meal, just have cash handy with the tip included
so that when the server comes over you can just
pay for it all at once. They bring you the check,
you look at the amount you probably know about
what it's going to be. You just give them the
cash. They go on with it. Rather than having
to give them a card. They leave, come back,
and then you fill out the tip and everything. It
saves you about half the headache because that's
one of the things that people hate most about
restaurants having to wait at the end of your
meal when you just want to get up and leave.
All right. That's going to do it for today's
show. My thank you to David for allowing
me to fill in for him today while he is
traveling up in Montreal. And we're going to
have Ferran Cousins fill in the next couple of
days. David will be back on Thursday and Friday
to finish out the week. And if you want more
of the David Pakman show, be sure to check out
today's bonus show, which you can access by
signing up for a membership at join pacman dot
com or contributing to Patreon at the $5 level
at Patreon E-commerce Slash David
Package Show. I'll see you on the bonus.